here we are with florine gergiel the
first romanian grandmaster the legend
of romanian chess how are you doing here
welcome to the crunches tour
well i was looking you know some of the
games they are very interesting it's an
honor for us to organize such a
tournament in bucharest again
and we hope that the best player will
win finally you know as always
well the the games are very interesting
until now and each day was full of
surprises and we'll see what happens in
the last three rounds
but
until now soy is doing very well under
onion also
and it's very difficult to change
something only in two days in the last
two days but we'll see
you know you never know
who am i rooting for in this event
well
my favorite was
fabiano before the game but right now i
i can't say that
he has the best chances to win
it depends you know luck in this
tournament and so on you know yes
only one romanian player bogdan deck
what do you think about him and his
career so far very well he's very young
you know only 20 years and until now he
was doing it very well unfortunately he
lost yesterday very unclear position
and it depends again what happens in the
last three games if he plays well
everything can happen as i told you
justice like that you know it's very
even until the end
we'll see
in our time was the same in this time
when you know
that
i can
tell you a little about this because
a long time ago i was three times
american champion i won three times the
american championship the u.s
championship
and this time the game was a little bit
different because the computer was not
there
and it was nicer i can say because
you could produce something you couldn't
you could show something right now it's
very difficult the machine is doing
everything and
the difference is too big you know the
machine is better right now
you started to say about your uh
participation in many international
events you played and i'm sure that you
have told a lot about it in your books
right can you tell about it a little bit
well these three books are about my
career and my life of course this is the
the title also you know is art in chess
and life you know the
title of these books and it's about a
period for 40 years starting in
1960 until 2000 when it was my best
period i was in the in the first 10 in
the world in this period and in one
moment after the third title in us
i reached the third place in the world
so there's a good period let's say yes
and the tournaments in united states
were also excellent very well organized
i have very good memories from this time
i played for about 25 years in the
united states so
you know we are good friends let's see
yes
sure and looking forward to seeing more
to see more about those books
very very good and very interesting but
we hope
in the
maybe in the next two three months
they'll be translated most probably also
in english and
it would be easier for everybody like
yes
it's great news actually
well we present here the best players
you know the nine world champion i have
uh
i had
the opportunity to
to play against nine world champions
starting with baldwin and till kramnik
you know all of them
kasparov
and so on
finally we have a lot of photos here
inside with kasparov and the last photo
from the third book is with him
with gary
so
most probably when we see each other
again i'll give him these books also and
i hope he'll appreciate this yeah that's
great news and actually we have yasser
sarawan and peter svidler in the studio
maybe you would like to say something to
yasser
is a very good friend we didn't see each
other for a very long time so what can i
say greetings
yes
[Music]